[Musique]
bonsoir à ceux qui nous rejoignent pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission
consacrée au débat des élections
municipales
place maintenant à vesoul la ville
préfecture de haute saône
voici les différents invités tous
candidats donc à l'élection pour la
ville de vesoul le 15 mars dimanche
tout d'abord alain chrétien maire
sortant de vesoul
il est maire depuis 2012 où il avait
succédé en cours de mandat à la joyeuse
des anciens et l'air pour ce scrutin
il porte aujourd'hui l'étiquette agir la
droite constructive et il a reçu le
soutien de la république en marche
frédéric bernabé du parti communiste
français conduit une liste divers gauche
il est conseiller municipal depuis 1983
il a été adjoint aux transports de loïc
neuf seront le maire socialiste de
vesoul entre 89 et 95 gens n'y a ni que
tu peins conduit une liste divers droite
il s'est déjà présenté lors du scrutin
précédent le gaz six ans il a été élu à
la ville de vesoul et à la structure
intercommunale
et puis marie dominique aubry ait l'air
conduit une liste divers droite
elle a été la première adjointe d'alain
chrétiens de 2014 à 2018
elle est conseillère départementale
quelques minutes avant la fin de ce
débat
david mal rédacteur en chef de france
bleu besançon interviendra à son tour et
vous posera madame et messieurs des
questions très précises
donc premier tour de table maintenant
l'ordre a été tiré au sort juste avant
cette émission sur les motivations de
votre candidature
on commence avec vous alain chrétien
vous avez donc changer d'étiquette en
cours de mandat métier l'air puis la
agir la droite constructive avec le
soutien de la république en marche vous
avez même un soutien de l'ancien de 2
l'ancien socialiste président du
département yves krattinger est-ce que
vous électeurs s'y retrouve là dedans
mais un bon soir on sera tous d'abord je
voudrais dire qu'en 2017 j'étais député
maire j'ai fait le choix de vesoul
par respect de la parole donnée
puisqu'en 2014 vous pouvez à l'époque
cumulé l'interdiction était votée entre
temps
j'ai choisi de rester maire de vesoul
par respect de la parole donnée aux
électeurs c'est pour moi essentiel
c'était une démarche fondatrice et je
souhaite poursuivre mon mandat de maire
pour suivre les projets eh bien pas du
tout répondu à ma question sur les
étiquettes j'allais venir je suis
soutenue par toutes celles et ceux qui
ont envie de faire avancer vesoul
vous savez une élection municipale on le
dit souvent c'est avant tout un candidat
un projet un programme une équipe c'est
là dessus que nous serons jugés évaluer
et puis c'est très bien si je peux
travailler avec le département la région
l'état
plus on sera nombreux à travailler
ensemble plus violent avancera genre
yannick tue pas il y a déjà deux listes
de droite sur vesoul
vous vous conduisez une liste divers
droite quelle alternative proposée vous
parce que nous sommes la meilleure tout
simplement je me présente et un bonjour
un jeune du pain j'ai voulu alice tu
veux vous appartient je suis élu conseil
municipal aussi municipal est
d'agglomération de la ville de vesoul
donc vesoul
j'y vis depuis toujours et j'ai vu soul
à coeur notre liste est composée de
femmes et d'hommes de tous milieux
excusez moi je vais vous interrompre on
va discuter plus longuement tout à
l'heure de vos projets c'est dans les
rares parce que life c'est vous lisez
votre petit papier c'est pas vraiment un
débat vous répondez pas vraiment à ma
question
frédéric bernabé vous vous étiez du
depuis je le disais tout à l'heure
37 ans est ce que la force vous n'avez
pas peur de lasser des électeurs bien au
contraire parce que je m'aperçois que à
ma première élection en tant que liste
est tête de liste et aujourd'hui je n'ai
fait que progresser
donc c'est plutôt la verse et on va dire
ou dire un peu des spécialistes entre
guillemets ça serait la bonne cette fois
ci voyez donc c'est avec enthousiasme
que je vais à cette élection là comme
d'habitude d'ailleurs parce que en même
temps c'est aussi un moment fort pour
faire réfléchir les la population les
vésuliens sur ce que disait
les chrétiens sur les projets là c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui on va faire une
analyse approfondie de la situation de
vesoul et quelle direction nous allons
prendre demain et celle inverse
je pense que les vésuliens avec
l'expérience m'attendent alors marie
dominique aubry vous êtes président
départemental des républicains on peut
dire qu alain chrétien c'est devenu
votre meilleur ennemi vous avez été sa
première adjointe pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez démissionné vous aviez déjà en
tête l'élection municipale de 2020 s'il
était resté chez les l'air est ce que
vous seriez encore candidate ou pas
alors j'ai déjà expliqué à maintes
reprises pour avoir pas chez nous alors
voilà alors je vais le redire
j'ai expliqué et je vais pas m'étendre
sur cette démission je pense que les
vésuliens attendent autre chose
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai démissionné en septembre 2018
parce que je souhaitais avoir la parole
et je souhaitais pouvoir parler aux
visions lien ensuite j'ai extrêmement
consulter et concertés ces vésulien
dois-je poursuivre cet engagement
pensez vous que ça vaut le coup et j'ai
été très encouragé très soutenu parce
que j'ai une vraie vision de vesoul
j'habite vesoul j'aime ma ville j'ai une
ambition pour cette ville cette ville
est en panne et j'ai un projet concerté
avec l'ensemble avec pas mal de vésulien
un peu plus de 1000 et je souhaite
pouvoir porter cette vision dès dimanche
alors un autre candidat est en lice
dimanche pour cette élection municipale
à vesoul il s'agit de cédric fischer
pour lutte ouvrière et nous explique
aussi pourquoi lui il propose sa
candidature depuis des mois les
personnels des hôpitaux dénoncent le
manque de moyens
les fermetures de lits et demandent dix
mille embauches avec l'épidémie du
coronavirus la situation risque de
devenir critique du côté économique
l'état annonce déjà des aides aux
entreprises ou du boost encore la
population qui a payé la facture
alors le pire de tout le pire fléau
reste capitalisme
dans cette élection aux municipales il
faut faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs élus nous serons non
seulement les yeux et les oreilles des
travailleurs mais aussi les
organisateurs des organisateurs de lutte
que ce soit au niveau de l'entreprise du
logement ou des transports le 15 mars
votez lutte ouvrière c'est voter pour
des militants qui affirment que seuls
les travailleurs mettront fin à la
dictature du grand capital et de ses
mercenaires politiques comme à plusieurs
reprises dans ces débats consacrés aux
élections municipales nous allons parler
tout d'abord du déclin démographique
c'est particulièrement vrai pour vesoul
qui a perdu deux mille habitants en 20
ans monsieur le maire quelle est votre
explication
écoutez la perte d'habitants elle
concerne beaucoup de villes moyennes
quasiment six vigiles nba viennent en
franche comté comme en région donc ça
n'est pas un phénomène uniquement centré
sur ces particulièrement fort chez vous
alors la ddt la différence c'est qu'à
vesoul
nous n'avons plus de terrain construire
depuis bien longtemps quand on fait des
lotissements et bien c'est facile on
propose à la population des terrains à
construire
sauf qu à vesoul ça n'est plus le cas le
dernier lotissement qu'on a pu
construire d'adia 15 à 20 ans donc il
faut refaire la ville sur elle-même la
reconstruire sur elle-même c'est
beaucoup plus complexe de faire du
logement en centre ville dans des
quartiers déjà urbanisées que de le
faire en utilisant les terres agricoles
donc c'est un vrai sujet frédéric
bernabé vous avez la même explication
que le maire sortant
non pas du tout vous avez indiqué on a
montré l'ampleur de ce phénomène puisque
on a perdu à peu près 20% de la
population sur deux décennies mais je me
porte en faux contre cette analyse tous
et partout la même chose non c'est pas
partout la même chose mais c'est partout
la même chose là où il ya eu les mêmes
réponses
c'est à dire on a fait du centre-ville
de beauce centre ville on a excentré les
commerces c'est à dire on a déplacé les
activités on a
comment on pourrait dire la fluidité des
transports
c'est de plus en plus complet fiq
complexifié et tout cela a mené à une
désertification à la fois des centres
villes mais aussi des populations va
interviewer aussi demandé à l'ancienne
première adjointe
vous vous êtes élu depuis 2000 ans de
sur la ville de vesoul vous sentez un
peu responsable des coupables coupables
je ne sais pas je dirais que c'est un
problème complexe la baisse de
population
on ne peut pas y apporter une seule
mesure et dire j'ai une mesure et je
résous tout je pense que il y a de
l'entreprise a trouvé pour que les
personnes restent sur place
il faut créer de l'emploi nous avons un
taux de chômage qui est important sur
vesoul et qui ne baisse pas ensuite nous
avons à trouver des formations pour les
jeunes pour que ces jeunes se forment
mais reste également chez nous et puis
enfin un cadre de vie amélioré qui est
bon mais qui est à améliorer et tous ces
leviers toute cette synergie de tous ces
leviers doit conduire à ramener de la
population chez nous alors j'en ai
effectué par vous vous êtes commerçant
vous avez un cinéma vous avez des
bureaux de tabac
cette baisse de population tant que
commerçant vous la santé oui oui non
écoutez les clients les a toujours et on
a quand même beaucoup de gens de
l'agglomération de vesoul qui viennent
faire leurs achats vesoul parce que
quand même on est motivés ou moins avec
mes collègues et on fait vraiment un
travail un énorme travail pour que tout
se passe bien pour eux et avec les
horaires est vraiment à leur convenance
elle pas à parler de l'agglomération
mais il faut dire que la démographie de
l'agglomération elle est stable
effectivement une commune comme echenoz
à la méline par exemple est passé de
1500 habitants à 3000 m et vous vous
êtes en dessous de 15 mg oui mais
l'agglomération est à 35 milles de
l'origine depuis une heure de la côte
est maintenant l'agglomération nomura
des impôts dgi elle doit s'imposer au
haut niveau il alors justement l'une des
conséquences directes
c'est l'augmentation de la dette puisque
on considère que vesoul est une ville
surendettée puisqu'il vous voudrez 14
années pour vous désendetter
est-ce que vesoul est une ville qui vit
au dessus de ses moyens
salé le problème de la dette ça fait
quinze ans que frédéric bernabé nous dit
qu'on est en banqueroute l'année
suivante
or on continue à investir pour vesoul
une ville qui est endetté est une ville
qui investit
effectivement entre 2000 et 2010 nous
avons beaucoup investi avec alain
joyandet jël assume nouveau théâtre
nouveau stade de foot passage à niveau
il fallait remettre à niveau de la ville
de vesoul est donc s'endetter pour
investir mais vous disais 2010 c'était
il ya dix ans et cette dette
elle existe et nous la remboursons sans
aucun problème puisque nous remboursons
des emprunts qui était à 3 à 4% et nous
en prenons maintenant à 0 8%
oui mais loyal d'habitants plus la dette
par habitant augmente le nom verte mais
c'est marginal
ce qui compte c'est si on peut
rembourser la dette et on avait besoin
de l'art en bourse alors est ce que
l'amérique bernabé vesoul est elle au
bord de la banqueroute
vesoul et en énorme difficulté je
reviens un petit juste une petite
parenthèse sur tout à l'heure il ya
aussi la disparition des services
publics dans notre ville qui est une
ville tertiaire qui a aussi augmenté la
démographie mais sur la dette sur la
tête c'est très simple c'est mécanique
une baisse de population là évidemment
elle gonfle par habitant derrière ça des
choix notamment hasardeuse avec des
emprunts toxiques en 2008 ou 10 millions
d'euros d'emprunts à 25% à la sortie
aujourd'hui
heureusement que l'état donne 325 1000
euros par an sur 14 ans 15 l'hélice la
mêlée et à régler nous quand même on
paye toujours cette d'état donc
aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'après il ya
la baisse des dotations et ses acquis
aussi fait que on a moins de ressources
mais l'essentiel aujourd'hui la dette
elle est là comment faire pour inverser
la tendance pour moi il y un vrai défi
c'est reconquérir de la population gagne
et de la population
sinon nous n'y arriverons pas et nous
serons dans une spirale de déclin comme
malheureusement d'autres villes ici
aujourd'hui
alors sur les finances et sur comment
faire venir de la population à vesoul
j'ai déjà un peu répondu sur comment
faire venir de la population sur les
finances
je rappelle que nous sommes la 31e ville
la plus endettée de france dette qui ne
baisse pas du tout contrairement à ce
que vous dites
elle ne baisse pas puisque nous
remboursons tous les ans toujours sur la
même sur les quinze ans et réemprunter
même à un taux très faible pour encore
rembourser cette dette c'est être
surendettés ça le prouve bien
alors moi je dis
qu'il ya des économies à faire on nous
demande à tous de faire des économies on
dit à nos habitants fait des économies
et bien nous allons faire en tout cas
c'est ce que je propose sur quoi sur
bien je vais vous le dire moi je vais
vous trouvez de l'argent faut en trouver
dans la halle enveloppe dis lui que je
baisserais de 2,50 m as assez marginal
sur le budget d'une virginale à millions
de route sur un mandat vous pouvez faire
un million de asud économie si vous
baisez n'ont ils pas je vais 500 mille
euros on n'est pas allé au madame aubry
c'est 1% des dépenses de fonctionnement
qu'est ce que vous faites des 99 autres
c'est une vraie question mais en tout
cas vous n'avez pas trouvé la solution
jusque là ce que je propose également ca
dans les économies à effectuer et bien
c'est de poursuivre ses économies en
sueur tout simplement les frais de
fonctionnement
pas de cabinet pour le maire moi je suis
pas là pour qu'on me fasse briller
je suis là pour faire briller ma ville
figurez vous et un cabinet qui coûte
cher ça peut aller jusqu'à 3 millions
d'euros sur le mandat je vous trouve 4
millions en lui en deux minutes
je pense qu'il faut un peu se pencher
sur le fonctionnement général de la
ville et celle là je crois qu'il y a des
vraies économies à réaliser
maintenant je suis d'accord avec
frédéric bernabé la population doit
revenir j'ai répondu comment faire pour
faire venir cette population à vesoul
mais en tout cas ce qui est embêtant
quand même dans cette dette
c'est que l'investissement est faible
une ville qui a investi est une ville
mois qu'on soit endetté
dont acte mais une ville qui investit ça
se voit vous avez des grues vous avez
dit ça bouge chez nous ça ne bouge pas
et elle investit
l'investissement est a minima alors j'ai
l'impression qu'on ne vit pas dans la
même ville on parle de deux grues hui
chez des grilles en a eu des logements
construits en centre ville y en a eu
je pense au foyer aubry 42 logements
construits entre le raisin ce lorraine
est la relève le noir l'ancien site de
l'hôpital près de 150 logements sont
sortis de terre il y à quelques quelques
mois seulement
donc j'ai l'impression quand j'entends
mais mes collègues qu'on ne vit pas dans
la même ville se dénigrent va on va
donner la parole à monsieur que je ne le
trouve pas dans la réalité
monsieur turpin vous vous dites dans
votre programme dans votre campagne que
vous voulez ramener deux mille personnes
à vesoul
vous faites comment oui alors j'ai des
solutions donc rénover les appartements
avec l'anah faire des loyers aussi faire
des efforts avec les propriétaires pour
avoir des loyers vraiment très bas pour
que les gens puissent revenir
par exemple nous on nous demande pas une
seconde et grands appartements où j'en
ai une paire que j'ai qu'on peut trouver
il ya vraiment une grosse demande avec
500 appartements qui sont vacants éco
rénovés avec des prix comme ça je pense
qu'on peut largement ramener sur les six
ans et du mime magie est réussi mais
c'est ce qu'on fait déjà on a mis en
place le pas et rue l'opération
d'amélioration de l'habitat
on a 200 logements qui sont en cours de
rénovation en centre ville on peut même
approcher les 70 % de subventions quand
vous êtes propriétaires occupants et
vous voulez rénover votre logement
donc on le voit les services publics
monsieur vers n'avait le palais de
justice vient de réintégrer son bâtiment
historique
ça va faire revivre toute une partie de
la ville quand on a tous ces projets sur
la cité jérôme sur l'ancienne caserne
on a plein de choses à la procédure
lancée pour dynamiser la ville monsieur
tu pars pour redynamiser la ville le
centre-ville vous proposez quoi même au
jeu j'ai proposé qui pue de cellules
vides avec un prêt qu'on ferait de 50000
euros
quelqu'un qui reprendrait une cellule
parce que vous savez et 10 nuls et
communiste celle de commerce and on the
wii une seule de commerce ou un fonds de
commerce si vous préférez et donc pour
piquer de deux cellules vides faute de
fonds de commerces vides ce que vous
savez le plus dur c'est d'avoir le prêt
et cette bande qui ne fait pas confiance
l'envi des français et des vésuliens
sont là devient s'installer à vesoul
mais ils n'ont jamais de près combien de
fois on voit qu'ils font et vous savez
aussi donc programme je fais une aide
aussi comment il ya les traites à payer
de trois comme c'est son devoir en ce
moment là c'est très très dur les traite
on saute à la banque
et comment on fait banque de france et
après plus de crédit du tout alors juste
la parole à frédéric bernabé pour
dynamiser le centre-ville par exemple il
ya la rénovation de l'ancien hôpital
paul morel concrètement vous proposez
quoi
juste un petit mot
on voit bien les difficultés ce qu'a dit
alain chrétien est très juste source qui
a été mise en place mais malgré ça la
spirale continue donc c'est beaucoup
plus grave que ça et moi un moment donné
j'avais dit j'avais souhaité que dans
une forme de consensus
il y un conseil municipal extraordinaire
sur cet affaiblissement de population il
a pas eu lieu c'est bien dommage alors
sur le dynamisme évidemment l'essentiel
c'est de revitaliser le commerce mais
pour cela il faut dire stop à cette
concentration de centres commerciaux en
périphérie et moi je dis ici je prends
un engagement devant les vésuliens
vésulienne pas d'oasis 4 je pense que ça
suffit là il faut que je décrypte un
petit coup si vous permettez pour
l'heure à côté de vesoul à la périphérie
de vesoul il ya le village de pusey avec
une très grande zone commerciale est
donc cette zone commerciale s'est
étendue dernièrement avec oasis trois
bad à mme aubry
doc si jamais vous est élu maire est ce
que donc la zone commerciale a puisé ces
temps ou pas certainement pas puisque
moi je me suis opposé déjà à l'oasis 3
alors je n'étais pas contre la venue d'
enseigne pascal mangier j'ai eu vraiment
tant qu'adjointe au commerce pour faire
venir les enseignes à l'heure actuelle
nous comptons au centre ville
quarante commerces vides et l'oasis 3
est certainement responsable car en la
carotte commerce vite sur combien ça
fait quoi comme pourcentage on va nous
en avons à peu près 20% ont peu près 20%
et os 10 heures chrono à 6 3 évidemment
alain chrétien va vous dire mais moi
aussi j'étais contre l'oasis 3 sauf que
quand vous êtes président de l'agglo et
que vous signez le plan local
d'urbanisme
eh bien vous signé les permis de
construire il fallait agir le monde
réalise le maire de blues qui s'il n'est
pas me construire ce n'est pas le plan
national et lui si vous connaissez mais
lui c'est la confiance est là depuis les
élus c'est le mélange est pas
responsables vont lutter ensemble contre
l'anc du roi à l'incrédulité hanche et
au dos à 3-3 à sumo ensemble d'avoir lu
devançant mais rien entre le 1 6 3 je
crois que vous l'assumez rien et pour
moi si vous permettez j'aimerais bien
continuer sur la peau va laisser le à
effectuer quand même par rapport aux
commerces
être maire c'est pas être amer
technocrates
être maître c'est mouillé est maire
s'est mouillé la chemise pour aller
chercher une nouvelle enseigne
être maire c'est faire des kilomètres
pour rencontrer des partenaires et leur
dirait bien qu'on voit là venez chez moi
parce qu'il y as à faire intervenir à la
crise ni rajuste attal est juste aussi
intervenir sur loupé un shérif qui est
une très belle à rodez on va fait réagir
alain chrétien sur cette histoire de
zones commerciales
parce que ce qui se passe c'est que le
maire de pisé est également le premier
adjoint de la structure intercommunale
donc là il y avait un peu on va dire
conflit d'intérêt entre une commune
périphérique l'agglo et puis vous en
tant que maire on était clair nous avons
voté contre l'oasis 3 nous sommes allés
en appel
quand on nous dit loi nous c nous ville
de zoug ville de vesoul municipal et
vous êtes allé en justes noces chaîne
adjointe au commerce l'association des
vitrines de buzz où nous sommes bel en
justice contre cette oasis la justice a
dit que cette zone pouvait se faire nous
sommes allés jusqu'au conseil d'état
maintenant elles existent moi je pense
aussi qu'il faut arrêter de dénigrer le
centre ville vous avez des commerçants
qui se battent pour se développer
vous avez des commerçants qui se
développe qui marche bien vous avez la
rosace lorraine par exemple qui était en
péril il ya quelques années qui
aujourd'hui renaît un centre ville et
des commerces qui ferment et les
commerces qui ouvrent nous avons mis en
place un fisac près de 400000 euros de
crédits d'état qui sont je voudrais bien
contrario l'hôpital commerce de
centre-ville l'hôpital j'ai aussi
d'anciens l'hôpital paul morel donc vous
vous avez un projet c'est d'en faire une
structure touristique haut de gamme pas
dire ça comme ça s'appellerait la maison
du vigneron s'est déchiré des photos du
vigneau château du vigneron ce sont des
financiers asiatiques notamment chinois
qui sont venus vous voir qu'ils veulent
acheter l'ancien hôpital paul morel vous
en tant que maire vous n'avez pas peur
quand vous voyez arriver des
désistements du financier extérieur
vous n'avez pas leur laisser les clefs
de l'hôpital comme ça moi ce qui me
rassure c'est qu'on a que certains est
envie d'investir à vesoul
moi je vais chercher des investisseurs à
vesoul il faut qu'une confiance qui
existe entre les élus et les
investisseurs priorat d'investisseurs
qui s'intéresseront à vesoul mieux ce
sera effectivement nous avons des
investisseurs qui sont intéressés pour
acheter l'ancien hôpital est le
transformer nous travaillons avec eux
nous obtiendrons les garanties
nécessaires
rien ne sera fait sans que les choses
soient clairement établies d'ailleurs
les services de l'état sont aussi sur le
pied de guerre pour vérifier
la provenance de ces investisseurs mais
c'est quand même bien d'avoir enfin des
gens qui s'intéressent à investir est
pas surdimensionné et on verra bien la
taille de la ville un peu d'ambition
quand on nous a dit que nous étions au
coeur des principaux vignobles français
pourquoi pas et en plus s'il fallait
investir pour rénover ce bâtiment
l'ancien hôpital avec des fonds publics
eh bien je mets au défi mes collègues de
les trouver dans le budget de la ville
ou même de l'agglomération alors marie
dominique aubry vous en pensez quoi de
ce projet et vous proposez quoi d'autre
à la place mme bien alors je vais
répondre à votre question
maintenant je voudrais quand même sur la
dynamique commerce répondre parce que
quand moi j'étais encore aux affaires
j'essaye de me lancer dans le débat gc
on essaye d'en manger des propositions à
faire avéré ni il resterait le temps
deux fois déjà très bien alors sur
l'ancienne dalle sur l'hôpital alors sur
l'hôpital moi j'ai une vision
complètement différente différentes
place aux jeunes nous avons près de 1200
jeunes me jusqu'à entre 1200 et 1400
jeunes post bac avec des formations qui
se font sur vesoul
les jeunes ont envie d'habiter à vesoul
ils ne peuvent pas je souhaite
développer une digital academy tout
simplement leur proposer de faire leurs
études et de rester sur place là de
créer une pépinière d'entreprises les
mettre en relation avec le travail avec
les instances entreprises on va donner
l'apparence 8,97 mais là ça va être
maintenant on va passer à autre chose
l'a dit rapidement dit la neuve il sait
s'appuyer sur le tissu associatif c'est
avoir des projets d'animation des
structures d'accueil pour l'aide aux
aidants c'est aussi un foyer-logement
peut-être un nouveau foyer au logement
il ya des services de proximité qui nous
font il ya le commerce mais il faut
aussi des gens qui viennent au commerce
parce que sinon ça ne sert à rien il
c'est cela l'essentiel est maintenant
est maintenant c'est l'heure que nous
attendons tous la venue de david mal
david mal je vous laisse vous installez
donc rédacteur en chef de france bleu
besançon il nous rejoint comme prévu et
c'est lui qui va vous poser quelques
questions très précises bon sens
catherine bonsoir à tous soit vous avez
beaucoup parler de déclin de spirale du
déclin d'un manque de grues vous avez
aussi évoqué alain chrétien
cette sensation de ne pas habiter dans
la même ville que vos concurrents sur
cette élection
j'ai envie de vous poser cette question
est-ce que vous assumez devant les
vésuliens en disant oui demain si je
suis réélu maire il faudra lutter contre
ce déclin il des clés relatifs
moi quand je croise des gens dans buzz
ou lé biz monsieur le maire qu'est ce
qu'on a une belle ville les gens de
l'extérieur nous dise quand on revient à
vesoul
qu'est ce que c'est beau qu'est ce que
ça a évolué les bâtiments sont
construits des grumes j'ai compté
pendant le mandat à un moment donné on
avait six grues au centre ville le
palais de justice l'ancien hôpital
bref vesoul est en train de se
transformer et quand j'entends parler de
vesoul dans ces termes de déclin de
morosité
il faut il faut être positif et voir ce
qui se passe et la réalité elles
existent quand vous allez au centre
ville et que vous avez 300 habitants
supplémentaires qui habite maintenant
des logements neufs mais ses habitants
ils consomment au centre ville la
dynamique elle est relancé et ça que je
ne comprends pas chez mille chez mes
collègues il ya un dénigrement de vesoul
qui ne porte préjudice à l'image de la
ville alors vous avez tous dit autour de
la table que vous aimiez vesoul qu'en
gros votre parti c'était vesoul votre
parti c'était la ville de vesoul
marie dominique aubry vous avez eu cette
expression en dix ans les 4 millions qui
manquent
les 4 millions d'économie je les trouve
en quelques minutes est-ce que c'est pas
un peu démago de dire ça si je suis élu
maire je fais des économies de 4
millions d'euros
on m'a demandé un exemple je lis de
nîmes il ya rien de démago dans ce que
je propose
et moi je m'engage à faire des économies
moi je m'engage parce que je dois pas
habiter la même ville que le maire de
vesoul à l'heure actuelle le malaise des
divisions lien je les écoute et jolie en
temps et c'est à victor avec eux que
j'ai partagé toutes ces évidences
quand vous parcourez le centre ville de
vesoul ils vont surtout noter les
magasins vides depuis un an et demi donc
je pense qu'il faut répondre en avec
vérité et ne pas se mettre un foyer
devant les yeux en se disant c'est super
on en a plus il y à des glissements en
fait on vit de certaines parties le
palais de justice revient très bien mais
quid du bâtiment du palais de justice
actuel
on vous dit les impôts vont réintégrer
une partie de l'inspection académique
et quid du bâtiment des impôts places
12e chasseurs donc à un moment donné il
faut trouver des solutions pérennes et
des économies oui seront nécessaires et
puis une question pour vous frédéric
bernabé puisque vous avez parlé vous
aussi de déclin et vous avez constaté
que la population était en baisse qu'il
y avait des emprunts toxiques
alain chrétien a eu cette expression
disant que c'était pas facile de lutter
contre cette spirale infernale de la
démographie parce qu'il n'y avait plus
de terrains à construire donc est ce que
c'est parce que c'est pas facile qu'il
faut s'abstenir de travail et non pas du
tout d'ailleurs moi je parle pas de
déclin c'est les chiffres de l'insee
et les chiffres de la dette c'est pas
les miens c'est ceux du conseil
municipal et que nous donne le maire
donc on peut pas les nier
après moi je vous comprends il ya une
période où c'était assez difficile de
construire c'est plus vrai aujourd'hui
de ce qu'on appelle les dents creuses à
peu dans notre jargon il y en a partout
du terrain il y en a aujourd'hui nous
pouvons construire mais il n'ya pas que
ça il ya tout ce que j'ai dit qu'ils
tournent autour c'est à dire le la
proximité les services de proximité nous
par exemple pour la jeunesse salle de
concert on voudrait de l'autre côté du
passage à niveau
faire un centre art parc pour l'art de
la rue lajeunesse et c'est pour que la
population revienne et se sentent bien
au centre ville il est hors de question
de dire que tout va mal et que rien n'a
été fait ça serait la démagogie
mais ce qui a été fait malheureusement
n'a pas été productif et c'est le
résultat
il faut se dire une chose quatorze 1950
l'homme de la femme bernadette en 1916
habitants aujourd'hui mais telle la
spirale demain ça sera encore mois très
bien merci beaucoup
david que de votre participation nous
allons maintenant passer à la conclusion
de ce débat vous avez chacun 30 secondes
pour conclure l'ordre est le même que
celui du début à la chrétien vous
commencez attention 30 secondes
on a fait une belle campagne une
campagne positive auprès des gens j'ai
revu beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit que
vesoul avancé que c'était fier de vesoul
on a fait une campagne sur trois
thématiques vesoul humaine
vesoul attractive et vesoul naturel des
thématiques qui sont retour qu'on
retrouve dans son petit fascicule que
nous avons distribué partout dans les
boîtes aux lettres
eh bien on va continuer à faire avancer
en étant positifs et ambitieux pour le
vesoul de l'avenir très bien jean
yannick tu penses et avoue alors vesoul
vous appartient c'est l'avenir
l'économie
le zénith le foyer-logement l'hôpital
nous on sera tout faire moi je sors du
privé et j'ai des façons de travailler
autre que et ce sera pour le meilleur
pour vesoul
merci frédéric bernabé 30 secondes pour
vous je suis très fier d'être tête de la
liste unie pour gagner qui est solidaire
et écologique
nous avons une équipe soudée c'est très
importante compétente pour un projet
solide dont j'ai donné quelques éléments
et qui donne et qui vont donner de
l'espoir aux vésuliens et au vésulienne
ce qui nous rend pleinement confiance
pour dimanche 15 mars
marie dominique aubry c'est à vous pour
finir ce tour de table ce projet que je
vous propose
et bien c'est avec vous je les construis
élaboré c'est grâce à vous que nous
avons cette vision pour vesoul et cette
ambition
alors ce projet ils vous ressemblent et
avec l'ensemble de mon équipe nous
aurons à coeur devrait quotidiennement
pour redynamiser vesoul renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat et la sécurité des
vésuliens alors dimanche en votant pour
moi vous voterez pour un maire à temps
plein pour les six prochaines années
pour une ville construite ensemble
autrement
très bien merci madame pour cette
conclusion je vous laisse maintenant
lire la liste des candidats présents au
premier tour dimanche 15 mars pour cette
élection municipale à vesoul donc il y
en a 5 5 en lice pour le premier tour
il me reste donc à remercier bat david
on va commencer déjà versé 4 en toute
confraternité merci david
merci madame et merci monsieur flûte
d'avoir participé à cette émission
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci de votre attention vous
téléspectateurs alors il me reste à vous
souhaiter une bonne fin de soirée puis
surtout à vous donner rendez-vous pour
dimanche soir 20h parce que ce sera le
premier tour et ce sera le grand moment
de ces élections municipales sur france
3 franche comté et sur notre site
internet dès 20h résultats analyses
commentaires tout sur ce premier tour
des élections municipales 2020 avec bien
sûr des directs en studio au kursaal à
besançon
alan desaulniers à belfort à vesoul et
des reportages un peu partout également
sur l'ensemble de la franche-comté
montbéliard pontarlier dole héricourt et
odin co voilà merci encore à tous pour
avoir participé à cette émission
merci de votre attention bonne soirée
[Musique]